[Music]
metro officers entering an apartment in
january were shot at more than a dozen
times in fact and they fired back and
killed a 19 year old well the entire
incident was caught on body cam video
and it happened near nellis and vegas
valley drive victoria saha joins us near
there and victoria the young man's
family is talking now about exactly what
happened
friends and family of isaiah williams
gathered here at the boulevard
apartments where he died demanding for
justice and change
this is what is left of the apartment
where 19-year-old isaiah williams was
shot and killed during a police raid
those police officers
[Applause]
taking responsibility for what they have
done in the early morning hours of
january 10 police were issuing a search
warrant for a suspect connected to a
murder that happened in november police
were begging in the door and announcing
their presence
when they entered body camera footage
shows williams was laying on the couch
by the door with a gun police say
williams fired 18 times at officers and
between five of them 23 rounds were
fired back at williams killing him i
don't want this to happen to anyone else
this is a horrible feeling to go through
to lose your child they're supposed to
be burying me not the other way around
friday's rally was to bring attention to
williams's death in the hands of police
the fact that he wasn't named in the
warrant and he was the one that ended up
dead
is a huge problem in a separate
interview with williams's mom last month
she says her son was a heavy sleeper and
was most likely startled by police
coming in she also says he was sleeping
in an unfamiliar place which is why he
could have had a gun my son was 19 years
old with his whole life
taken from him
williams's mom also says her son did not
know that suspect that police were
looking for police were able to arrest
that correct suspect a few days later
and we learned those charges for that
suspect were dropped a few weeks ago
reporting live tonight victoria saha
live local now victoria thank you